Cory I know as we were setting up for
the interview you mentioned about the
last three years being much different in
terms of the screenwriting and getting
out there right you talked about some of
those changes the currency yeah and
especially in TV writing where a lot of
the action is so if you go back 10 or 15
years and you ask yourself of all the
scripts that are sold let's put them
into three different categories we have
paradigm driven scripts we could also
call these formula driven rules driven
so these are scripts where like if you
watch a bunch of three camera comedies
it's the same story structure just
different joke or you watch a bunch of
superhero movies over the summer it's
kind of the same story beats are happy
at the same time so these are formula or
paradigm driven scripts so that's one
category of scripts that people can
write and try to sell then there's
imitative scripts so when Breaking Bad
was a phenomenal hit everyone's writing
their version of Breaking Bad or people
write their version of Arrested
Development so you'd read someone's
script and you'd be like oh this is like
Mad Men but kind of different and then
the third kind of script is pitch
perfect authentic and so that would be a
script that like when you read the pilot
script for orange is the new black it's
not like anything you've ever seen it's
like orange is the new black love it
Mike it hate it is completely original
we've never seen these characters we've
never seen this world and the story is
not formulaic it doesn't hit these
preordained plot points it unfolds in a
way that's most compelling for what
Jenji Kohan the writer is trying to
communicate Mad Ben's another example
community Sopranos we just go on and on
moonlight so these are scripts that
don't follow a paradigm they don't
imitate what somebody else did they're a
wholly original piece of work original
characters story and way of telling that
story so if we go back 12 or 15 years on
the TV market who's buying pitch-perfect
authentic scripts HBO Showtime that's it
everyone else is basically buying
paradigm driven shows genre driven shows
or a show that imitates a successful
show so
if you want to break into the business
10 years ago even seven years ago you
might follow a formula you might follow
a paradigm also you're looking to get
staffed on a TV show so TV shows hire
lots of writers so if you want to be a
comedy writer you might write an episode
of jane the virgin or episode of silicon
valley
you're a drama writer you'd write a
version of a drama to prove it you could
imitate a show everything is completely
different now so now when you ask
yourself who's buying pitch-perfect
authentic scripts HBO Showtime Netflix
Amazon a.mcf X and the network's
basically everybody and the reason is
they're all chasing the key demographic
which is 18 to 49 and our generation
we've grown up on on-demand video demand
platform so we've seen so many movies
we've seen so many TV shows we know
what's original and we know what is
imitative and by and large our
generation doesn't watch formula and so
basically the the key demographic wants
something that's original want something
that's new and different and there's so
much you can watch on TV it really needs
to be special to grab your attention and
so you'd be loyal so people are loyal
transparent they're loyal to Game of
Thrones they're loyal to Jane the Virgin
and these are pitch perfect authentic
shows so I've read every script that is
sold in the last three years and the
vast majority are pitch perfect
authentic scripts now there are paradigm
driven scripts that sell their our
imitative scripts that sell but the
people who sell those are people who
have a real serious track record in that
genre and what agents will always tell
my classes is if you have a standard
follow the dots comedy or drama or
procedural unless you've been an
executive producer above on a hit show
in that space in the last three years
your scripts dead on arrival normally
even read the script further showrunners
now when they staff shows they won't
look at imitation scripts they don't
want to look at your version of a show
they want to read a pitch-perfect
original
scrip and what they always tell my
classes is if you can write to a show if
you can imitate my voice if you can
follow a paradigm or a formula that
doesn't mean you're a great writer if
you're an amazingly great writer you can
eat my voice you can follow how I tell
my stories so it's really heartbreaking
because there's so many books and
classes and seminars that probably made
a lot of sense five years ago that are
teaching people these paradigms or
teaching people how to imitate and a set
of rules that no longer applies
so it's like writers are being trained
for a war that doesn't exist anymore and
just real quick in features if you're
going to work for the studio's you are
going to be doing a Pixar film a Star
Wars film or a Marvel action song that's
basically sure three choices and they
Pixar has a way they tell their stories
Marvel has the way they tell their story
Star Wars has a way to tell their story
but I have students I have a student
who's got her first writing job at Pixar
but the script that she wrote was a
pitch-perfect authentic script so even
though when they hire her they're going
to expect her to write a Pixar script
you don't break in with a Pixar script
you don't break in imitating or
following a formula you break in with a
script that when everyone reads that
they go holy moly who wrote this this is
amazing this writer I have to meet this
writer I have to be in business with
those writers so when you look at the
writers who are writing all the features
for the studio's they either have
amazing track record of credits like
Lawrence Kasdan or they wrote an amazing
pitch perfect authentic script that no
one had seen before blew people away and
then Marvel's like hey would you be
interested in doing our you know
whatever movie we're making and yes at
that point when you got hired you're
certainly going to write it the way
Marvel wants you to write it but the
mistake I see has so many writers write
their superhero scripts or their paint
by the number of scripts and they can't
figure out why they can't get a career
they're just simply writing the wrong
kinds of scrubs
Corey what are some of the tell-tale
signs when you but they have a student
in one of your classes that they're
using this old model that it may just be
three years there was an outdated way
but but what are some typos so when I
work with writers I separate story
design from story execution so story
design is just so if you were going on a
vacation and you wanted to have a
romantic relaxing vacation and you ended
up in a war zone where people are
completely getting killed
there's no room service because
everyone's dead dead bodies in the pool
can you have a relaxing romantic
vacation and the answer is you could but
it's very unlikely if you go to a very
relaxing romantic resort and
everything's perfect that doesn't
guarantee that you'll have a relaxing
romantic vacation because you still have
to have the vacation and you might be
stressed you might be thinking about
work you might be having a fight with
your partner but if you go to a very
relaxing romantic spot you you get there
in a you know fly first-class or you
take a night train through Europe and
every the design of your vacation is
just perfect it makes it so much easier
to have a relaxing romantic vacation the
mistake that so many writers make is
they have a problem with their story
design but they try to fix it through
execution so that's like you're in a war
zone let's turn the volume up so we
don't hear the dead people as much let's
take the dead people out of the pool yes
that does make it better but just leave
and go to Hawaii and you'll be in much
better shape so I always start with
story design and make sure people I'm
sorry if I cab a cup so the key is when
someone's having a problem with their
script is it a problem with design or is
it promised execution because other
writers will have a great design but
they'll mess it up in execution get
feedback that it's not working and throw
their design out so if there's a problem
with design and you keep trying to fix
it an execution that's like rearranging
the deck chairs on the Titanic but the
same time you might have a great story
design that you just aren't able to find
the right execution so people will often
do a consult with someone and the
scripts pretty good but the ending is
terrible and when I talk to them it
always comes up we're like well that's
not my original ending and I go what is
your original ending and when they tell
me I'm like that's a great ending like I
know but everyone said I didn't believe
it it was trite they have one had
criticisms they were criticizing the
execution not the design so the sorry
I'm taking a long way around to the
question but so when I'm working with
story design it's when someone is
working from a formula or a paradigm or
a set of rules first of all you're just
not interested when you hear it it's
incredibly predictable and it just feels
generic it feels like an Ikea piece of
furniture it's like I've seen this story
a million times and the other key thing
is at some point I'll just stop them and
I'll say why does this happen like why
did the character do this and the real
answer is because the writer wanted or
needed or felt like they needed the
character to do this so it's not
authentic it's non-organic and it's not
the best way of telling the story if
it's literally following a recipe okay
so how are you I'm fascinated by this so
let me just see if I can understand the
difference between design and execution
so design is like the structure of it
and they're doing this perfect sort of
three-act structure but it's too
predictable
whereas execution are the little details
no execution is actually when you're
writing so it's the dialogue it's the
characters it's the comedy it's the
actual writing of it the design is
having the entire story worked out
before you've written a word okay and
you need to be able to create pitch
perfect design and then execute it
authentically where these are real
characters that were compelled with and
everything that's happening feels this
is really what the character would do
but it also is what's really interesting
to the story because the problem that a
lot of writers get into is if they
slowed things down they'd realize that
there's key points in their scripts
where they ask themselves if this was a
real person with character what would
they really do and let's say it's this
they would do this then they ask
themselves from a story point of view
what makes for the most interesting
story and it's that and so some writers
will just do what the
character would actually do and their
scripts feel very organic but they're
not strong stories other writers will
follow oh this is what makes for the
best story but so they have good strong
structure but doesn't feel organic or
believable so one of the key skill sets
and so when I work with writers this is
the the first thing that I teach them
and I think that this is the
foundational skill set and I call it
creative integration and so the way it
works is writers tend to work from one
of two places inside themselves and it
has to do with the brain and there are a
conceptual part of the brain and
intuitive part of the brain and most
writers tend to be more conceptual or
more intuitive so conceptual writers
tend to work outside in they tend to be
very concerned about the story that the
story logical that the story makes sense
that the story is interesting to other
people conceptual writers are very
concerned about what other people are
going to think about this writing and
will they think this is good they think
I'm a good writer so they want really
interesting things happening and they
want a lot of interesting things
happening and they want it to make sense
and they wanted to have causality and
that's really really important to them
intuitive writers are completely
different the intuitive part of the
brain doesn't care what other people
think it just cares about what is
authentically true to you so intuitive
writers are navigating towards what they
would do in that situation or just
what's interesting and compelling to
them or what the character would really
do and it's a very different way of
writing one the conceptual is outside in
and the intuitive is inside out so a
conceptual writer would say I have this
great idea and I've got to figure it out
I got to break the story before I could
write it if you don't know where you're
going how you're going to get there it's
a very systematic logical approach to
writing the intuitive writer is going to
be someone who says I need to write this
out to figure out what the story is they
find it through the journey they find it
through exploring intuitive writers
explore conceptual writers decide and
they each have different inherent
strengths and weaknesses so let's start
with conceptual writers conceptual
writers when you ask them why did you
write this what why is this script
important to you it's almost always a
big idea a let if something that could
be commercial a new way of doing a
comedy I thought this was a great idea
for a horror film or it's a theme they
want to explore an intellectual theme
and so they're really good at big ideas
big concepts and they're really good at
making sure everything happens for a
reason and there's forward momentum and
there's causality and they have lots of
interesting things happening that we're
just not that interested in and one of
the reasons we're not that interested in
it is their characters are never
compelling enough their characters feel
kind of like they were invented to tell
this story because they work they're
kind of like puppets who are there to
tell the story and we just don't get an
emotional connection to the characters
the other reason that they hit a glass
ceiling they can't get through is
there's all these interesting things
happening in the script but we're not
that interested in them because we don't
feel anything because the writer didn't
feel anything when they wrote it and
it's an energy transference business so
conceptual writers got great ideas
lots of big great things happening but
the characters just aren't where they
need to be and it's just not emotionally
engaging and most of those writers know
that they don't know what to do about it
and Tudor writers are the opposite they
believed on the page and these
characters are like real people to them
they don't invent the characters they
don't designing the characters they
discover them and that's why a lot of
intuitive writers don't often get lonely
when they write because they're spending
time with their friends they're spending
time with people that they care about
and so if I'm working with a conceptual
writer and the character is not engaging
enough they'll say well what can we do
to change it should we make her older
younger let's make her bisexual let's
change or ethnicities let's take her arm
off let's make a record Ripley Jack what
can we do to make her
if I'm working with a deep intuitive
writer and their characters aren't
interesting enough that would be like
talking to a mom and saying your
daughter is not that popular at school
let's take her arms off let's make her a
quadriplegic let's make her older if you
like that's crazy this is a real person
you can't change who they are intuitive
writers like they're very connected to
their characters and as a result they
tend to create really compelling
characters really compelling emotion and
these really compelling characters are
forever searching for a compelling story
they can't find because the intuitive
writer is so inside out and so connected
to emotion and character that part of
them cannot create strong story it's the
the conceptual brain has a perpendicular
processor and it has a certain way of
syncing and strength so weaknesses into
the brain as a parallel processor and
anyone if they're interested on you can
email my assistant which is Lisa at Cori
Mandel net and we can get you a bunch of
information on this if you're interested
but to take this further what happens is
most writers if not all writers when
they're writing they're trying to write
the best script they can write and if
you're smart and writers are very smart
you play to your strengths and you hide
your weaknesses so if I was a playing
tennis against you for the championship
and I'm really good at my forehand but
I'm weak at my backhand I would try to
play everything than my forehand and
hide my and you of course would try to
make me play my back here so writers are
always writing to their strengths and
trying to hide their weaknesses and
maybe they know they're doing it maybe
they don't but they're doing it I see
this all the time and so what happens is
over time as their strengths get
stronger and their weaknesses get weaker
and that is why there's so many writers
who poor heart and soul and all this
time and energy to have a career and
they can't get there because your
scripts aren't quite good enough when I
work with the writer I will train them
through creative integration so what we
will do is we will make them write to
their weakness and hide their strength
so if I'm right hand I do everything is
my right hand and my left
really uncoordinated I literally tighten
my right hand behind my black my back
for a month and I do everything my left
hand it's going to get stronger and more
coordinated now during that month I
might spill a lot of things and be very
inefficient but over time I'll develop
my left arm and coordination in the
strength then I'll learn how to
integrate the two so for a conceptual
writer they will work exclusively from
the intuitive part they will learn how
to turn off the conceptual part the
conceptual part is the part that has all
these big ideas and worries about story
a lot is all this anxiety and judgement
and turn that off and teach them how to
create from a pure authentic emotional
space now their writing may not be well
structured it may not be something
they're going to show an agent but they
will through that process their
characters will come alive their
dialogue will come alive and you'll one
of the key things when I do intuitive
training is to get you to think about
something in your life where you feel
something very strong and then you're
writing when other people read it
they're going to feel what you feel so
you can get people to have the emotional
experience you had when you wrote it
then when I help you learn how to
discover actual characters and a whole
bunch of training to get to the point
where that's a real person for you then
you can write that person from what
they're feeling and people will feel
that then you can start putting
characters into conflict and it will all
be authentic characters and so that's
the intuitive training and when they get
to the point where their characters and
their dialogue and everything is organic
and authentic as best of the best
writers out there then I'll teach them
how to integrate that back to the
conceptual side so that they all have
the best possible stories and the best
possible characters and then obviously
for and into two writers the opposite
they will turn that part of the brain
off they'll work purely from conceptual
until they're a rockstar and then we'll
integrate and that process it's just so
rewarding to work with writers because
if they come out the other end literally
their agent their manager or their
spouse will say but we the script and
say I love you but you didn't write this
I hear this all the time I don't believe
you wrote this because your stories
aren't this crisp and compelling this
has all your great character work but
you can't like who helps you with the
stories or someone will say you don't
write characters this great I love you I
love your writing but
this was like you know orange is the new
black or Maddy I mean this is just that
high level of characters and it's like
it literally is transformative and then
the last thing I'll say which is really
cool about creative integration is that
most writers occasionally they have
these flow days where everything is just
pouring out of them and it's so great
you're doing your best material and you
love those days and you wish you could
live in those days and then writers have
those days which is the exact opposite
where you're pounding your head against
the wall just trying to get something on
the page and I think for most writers
that I work with they're often somewhere
in between the really great thing about
creative integration is almost all your
days will be flow days because this is
what cause float this is what happens
when a writer is writing there's what
would be best for the story what is the
best thing to make the story move for in
the most interesting way and a lot of
writers especially intuitive writers
they don't know the answer and that's
really confusing and frustrating excuse
me now even if you do know the answer
and let's say it's that then of course
what would my character really do and if
it's the same thing and then you ask
yourself what do I most want to write
today what gets me most exciting about
writing date it's the same thing all
three navigational systems lying up
that's a float that's when it's all
coming out of you it's your best writing
you want to live in those days when you
don't know what the character would do
or you don't know what's best for the
story or you know but this is what's
best for the story this is what the
characters do this is what you both want
to write it's all those are the worst
days so the creative integration does is
it allows people to train and know what
the set of suite of tools what would be
best for my story they'll be able to go
to another part and know what my
character really do those another part
and know what they're most interested in
writing and then they'll have tools to
integrate which is to bring those three
things into alignment and so I can't say
that every writing day will be a flow
day but most of writers are trained
they'll say used to be 10 to 20 percent
for flow days now it's like 80% and so
they not only does the quality of the
writing greatly improved sort of
quantity so let's say somebody knows you
know I'm very right brained very
intuitive right and I resonate with
music and emotions and color right but I
really have trouble connecting the dots
right and staying on task right and I'm
actually speaking personally about
myself so if I know that about myself as
a writer and I know that what's going to
show up on the page is that the story is
going to lack any kind of continuity
probably there's going to be with some
issues how do I rein myself in because
as a right brain person that that's one
of my issues I have trouble reining
myself sure so how would somebody who's
so used to being oh I'm going to go with
this emotion I'm gonna go with this
right so make themselves more linear so
it's different for every writer but
generally speaking what I would probably
do if I was working with you is the
first thing I would say is we're going
to turn off your intuitive side and
develop your conceptual sight so that
you're going to be able to naturally and
easily build to connect the dots but not
only connect the dots but do it with
real strong stakes and clarity and
strong escalations and you're going to
be able to create as strong of a story
as anyone in the industry and that story
in a sense is is a glass and then we're
going to teach you how to pour your
characters and your dialogue and your
emotion and all that intuitive stuff
into that structure so that now your
characters and your dialogue will be in
service of a super strong story so and
then usually the writers like oh that's
exciting I want to do that how do I do
that then I say okay well here's step
one I need to imagine that we're going
to go behind the barn and take
everything that you love about writing
and we're just going to shoot it in the
head and that's the writers like I don't
want to do that but that's what it feels
like is what we need to do is turn off
that part of you that is that dreamy
intuitive emotional connective
instinctive part of you now we're not
going to kill that forever that is such
a valuable part of you but we are
literally going to turn it off because
here's the thing if it's on your
conceptual brain can't be on they both
can't be on the same time they're
connected by a corpus callosum and just
physiologically speaking they can't be
on
same time it would it would
short-circuit the fight-or-flight
mechanism so we're going to turn this
off and so the training in the beginning
is we're going to be creating simple
stories and then more complex stories
and eventually scripts that there'll be
no characters and there'll be no
dialogue and we are literally like going
to be playing with just puppets and we
are going to be doing we're going to
going to drill you day in and day out
week in and week out on exercises for
story logic and for story company but so
if I may back up the there's a really
cool class up there called drawing from
the right side of the brain I'm sorry
yeah driving fire so they bring and they
have the before and after pictures they
have these people who are terrible
illustrators they do self-portraits and
you look at it and you're like you I
wouldn't even call these stick figures
because I'd be an insult stick figures
these are durable joined and then they
have three days later the same person
does their same self-portrait and it's
like this is amazing like how could
someone in three days go from being such
a terrible drawer to such an amazing car
and so the key is she has broken down
the drawing into five specific skill
sets and one of them is contrast one of
them is shapes and this is the key she
teaches you contrast or she teaches you
shapes completely separate from all the
others so you can't learn shaping if
you're worried about what the picture
looks like if you're worried about it
being a good picture you just learned
shaping you just learn contrasts you
just learn color I actually don't know
what the five things are by heart but
you learn all five things in isolation
and then the end should teach you how to
integrate it so that's what we would do
so we would be drilling you on story
logic and you'd have a whole week of
those exercises but they're not real
characters it's not a script you're
working on these are just training
exercises then we're going to drill you
on five weeks of story causality then
we're going to work on logic and clarity
and perspective and then we're going to
be working on escalation then we're
going to be creating conceptually strong
characters and moving them and you're
going to ultimately create a story where
we don't know anything about the
characters we have no emotional
connection but when you look down at
that story you're going to say that is a
clear beginning
and it has forward momentum and
escalation if that story was populated
with super compelling characters and
dialogue it could be amazing
and yours gonna be able to do that over
and over again you probably won't enjoy
this training it probably won't be fun
in fact writers usually complain because
they're like this feels like math and
this is I want to be a writer because I
hate math right when can we do this fun
stuff and it's like you cannot do the
fun stuff until you are an expert at
this because here's the truth and this
is really sad intuitive writers when I
read their I'll give you a true story
I'm a mentor for filming the pendant and
they have a lab and they bring in these
writers and then you are mentored by
writers and directors of some of the
best independent films and I came in at
the end sort of clean up where the
writer had all these notes and before
they went to do the rewrite I would work
with them sort of make sure their plan
was in good shape so I kind of came at
the end of the process and I worked with
this writer it's wonderful woman and she
had gone to one the major film schools
and had an MSA and she ever since she
was a little girl all she wanted to do
is be a writer and she she was so
excited to get in this program and she
had written the script and some of the
writers and directors of her favorite
movies read your scripts and gave her
feedback and so my job is to see what
her rewrite plan is and see if I can
bring any value to it so I go hey how's
it going just it's going good but she
said it and I really like things are not
going good way and I goes what's going
on shows I quit and I'm like you're not
going to write this shows no I quit and
I'm like what do you mean shows I'm not
gonna write anymore I'm done
and I couldn't be happier this is a load
off my shoulder and like she starts
crying it's so sad and this is a very
representative story I see this all the
time so I get in touch why are you
quitting what happened so what happened
is she's this really intuitive writer
and so she's in this program and she had
a character she loved more than anything
and she loved the story more anything
she wrote this script and she said
everyone was giving me feedback Dave it
was like the feedback with contradictory
like they all read a different script
that's what happens with intuitive
writers because they have no they have
no story structure and they have no
clarity and literally everybody
does read a different story so all these
really great writers and directors were
giving her feedback on the stories that
played in their head when they read the
script none of them were the story that
played in the writers head but the real
coup de Gras was she knew she wasn't
good at story structure but she thought
she was great at characters and they all
told her your character is not that
strong you you need a write stronger
character so she said I can't do story
structure and my character is not that
good and these are the best people
industry telling me that I got nothing
so I have to quit I got nothing to hang
my hat on so I said do me a favor before
you quit
we just answer some questions and so she
said okay so I asked her all these
questions about her character
why didn't you love your character and
what does your character do and tell me
about the story and what happens here
and why does this happen and and we
after about an hour of questions I could
really experience and see what she was
seen in the experiencing and it was one
of the most hauntingly beautiful
characters and it was such a great story
but I told her I got almost none of that
when I read your script and the movie
that plays in my head when I read your
script it was really boring and I didn't
understand or care about your character
but the character that you experienced
the character that's inside of you that
is a really powerful character you need
to learn how to develop these conceptual
tools so that you can take this amazing
character this amazing wine and get it
into the right vessel the right
structure not a formulaic structure but
a custom design structure that will
showcase your character in a story you
want to tell and she's like I like to
never do that I could have in anyway she
did end up taking classes from me and it
took her longer than most people it took
her probably a year to get really strong
at the conceptual site and probably
another year to really learn how to
integrate that that she then wrote that
script everybody loved it she didn't
sell it that she got an agent off of
that and now she's a very successful TV
writer and the funny thing actually is
the person who hired her at one point
said you're you're really great with
characters but I just hired you because
you were I just knew
someone who's so good with stories and
she could see had to call me because
he's like I got hired because they think
I'm really good at story the thing is
she's really good at story it's almost
like someone who's been heavy their
whole life and now their sin they still
think they're heavy like she still it
took a while for her confidence to catch
up to her abilities so what breaks my
heart is that there's all of these into
two writers out there and people are
reading the scripts and they're just not
that interesting they're not that good
but if you could know what was playing
inside their heads and their hearts
you'd be like now that's powerful but
they don't know that and they don't
train themselves so it's like how many
you know how many trans parents have the
world not had or how many Sopranos or
moonlight how many of these projects
never came to fruition because there's a
writer out there who has something like
that inside them but they can't get it
on the page where we can experience it
and conversely you have these conceptual
writers I have a Nick who's one of my
students who then went on to sell a
script and and directed and invisible
sizable hit so now he's kind of a big
new comedy guy so he's looking for his
next project to direct and we had lunch
a few weeks ago and he's complaining
because he's like I'm reading all these
scripts they are so smart there's a
great premise for a comedy there's all
these funny set pieces but these
characters feel like stock characters
they feel like characters I've seen
before and it's funny but there's no
heart to it like he wants to do is you
kind of do something like in the vein of
Groundhog Day something that's funny but
it has some heart to it it has some
depth to it and he's like all these
writers can't do that and then I read
these other writers and they've got so
much depth but it's just so incoherent
and mess right so these conceptual
writers when I work with them if they
are working from a pure intuitive place
that the metaphor I would give a
conceptual writer is you're writing a
horse and you need to get home and
you're guiding the horse is taking it
there but you're guiding the horse you
are the conceptual person the horse is
the intuitive and you're guiding the
horse where you want it to go sometimes
when you get lost you have to let the
horse guide you
and that's what we're going to do is
we're going to let your inner horse your
inner intuitive just take you over it
wants to take you to and you're not
going to judge it you're not going to
control it now it's going to take you
wandering around and you're like this
isn't a good story this is off topic
this is de-escalating no one's going to
be able to care about that yeah the
horse knows where it's going and the
journey won't be a great story but the
horse is going to take you to some
clearing with the Sun and the lake that
it's just going to be the most beautiful
place you've ever been and and it is
going to be life-changing that you
experience that and then we'll teach you
how to create a story around that space
but you'll never find that inside you
and let until you let the horse just go
where it wants to go but most
consumption or like okay I'll let the
horse take me at once and a horse starts
doing pages and it's like yeah but this
part of the forest is boring I'm bored
by I know a reader be bored but I
couldn't sell this anywhere okay stop it
horse I'm gonna help because you don't
know what you're doing it's like no the
horse is taking you somewhere if you let
it
and so sorry for talking your ear off
but I think what for me what is so
frustrating is that there are writers
out there that sacrifice so much in
terms of time and money because they
want to be writers and they're you know
that you have to work a lot you know you
have to write a lot of scripts and all
that time and energy is time energy that
you're not spending elsewhere in your
life it's a big sacrifice plus they
spend money on classes and seminars and
books and software and it's a big
investment and they have a dream and
they want to tell stories and they want
to live a creative life and they want to
bring their visions to life for other
people and so many of them they just
like keep writing all of these scripts
thinking they're getting better but
they're just creating a larger pile of
similarly flog scripts and it's because
they don't have the right tools they
don't have all the right tools and just
as an example there's so many writers
that were like I know my characters and
dialogue aren't that strong Balinor to
do about that just things are something
wrong with me and then they always write
big concept comedies or big concept
thrillers where it doesn't matter if
your characters are that good because
they love to write the King's Speech
they'd love to write Silicon Valley they
loved write Mad Men but they're like
not good enough and their agents and
managers that won't find them because
they're like I can teach you structure
to some extent I can't teach you an ear
for dialogue I can't teach you the right
but if you don't have that you don't
have that but what I would tell those
writers is if you want to be a carpenter
and you want to pound nails into wood
and you can't do that you can't pound
nails into wood you're never going to be
a carpenter and people are trying for
years to panel nails into wood and it
doesn't work and they're like I guess I
just suck as a carpenter but no they're
using the straw they're using a drinking
straw to pound those nails into it
they're using the wrong tool if you gave
them a hammer they might be a little
clumsy up but after they got good with a
hammer they're like oh I can do this
their conceptual writers are using their
conceptual tools to try to create
characters it doesn't work and intuitive
writers are trying to drink a milkshake
with a hammer you know so if we can give
everyone a straw and a ham if we can
give people the various tools get them
really good at those tools then suddenly
writers can write at a whole nother
level they didn't even know existed
it sounds like left brain ie conceptual
writers have a lot of trouble letting go
they're just they're so formulaic and
there's so much about you know making
sure that this makes sense and that you
know whereas with these right brain
people they're just all over the place
and there's just too easily led so it
sounds like you do exercises to help the
left brain people let go and the right
brain - yeah so or no thing so it's a
great video that can send people again
you can email my system which is Lisa
creme Internet and so it's neurologists
and she'll really break down the
conceptual intuitive parts of the brain
and literally what one part is good at
where the part is good at but they can't
talk to each other these because they
have a different processor it's like the
old days with pcs and Apple so like you
have a dream which is a very intuitive
experience nonlinear non-causal but it's
really evocative and you try to tell
someone about the dream which is a
conceptual exercise and the best you can
do is kind of like get them to go oh I
see how you had a really interesting
dream but they don't necessarily
experience it that way
so yeah it's the the hardest part is
turning off your
home base and then when I can get you
over to this other side I will give you
exercises because everyone knows about
the 10,000 hours to become an expert at
something well even Malcolm Gladwell has
said the 10,000 hours was the wrong
thing to focus on that there's nothing
magical about 10,000 hours what he said
was 10,000 hours of dedicated practice
everyone latches on in 10,000 hours
everyone forgets dedicated practice
dedicated practice is way people become
an expert in something is sure they got
put a lot of time and energy and passion
into it but it's not it's what they do
what their training is how they train
and so if you think about if you want to
be I trained at Second City improv they
don't let you on stage for a year and a
half because they are you're doing
specific exercises every day to learn
certain key skill sets that ultimately
they'll integrate together and then
they'll put you on stage same thing with
Juilliard and acting same thing if
you're a professional athlete
it's about specific exercises to train
yourself to develop the key skill sets
and integrate and so I and I'm sure
we'll talk about this at some point now
I was a working studio writer for 11
years and while I did that I taught once
a year at UCLA to give back and for fun
and then over the last six years I've
been building a teaching business and
teaching and working with rioters and I
have a lot of friends and a lot of
people who are very successful writers
and almost all of them either figured
all this stuff out themselves which
takes about 10 to 12 years for most
people or they had someone help them and
use two kinds of people that helped them
a manager or they get to be a writers
assistant and staffed on a TV show and
that showrunner following that
showrunners process I know someone who
worked on Breaking Bad and working with
Vince Gilligan for three years taught
her how to change her process protected
to the greatest story she was very
intuitive and she got on to Breaking Bad
and Breaking Bad what will happen is in
gaining the season Vince Gilligan Alaska
all the writers in the room to come up
with certain ideas and pitched ideas and
if you like the idea he writes it on an
index card and it goes on the board and
ultimately there's all these ideas on
the board that they're going to start to
work with to develop the the season well
if you're a new writer you really want
to get a lot of ideas on the board
because if he's going around the room
and none of your ideas get on the board
that doesn't look so good
well his rule was the idea had to fit on
the card so if you start pitching an
idea and he's writing and he runs out of
room might be a great idea but he ran
out of room on the card it doesn't go on
the board and she's like I couldn't get
my ideas out concisely enough she said I
didn't know how to speak an index card
and so she had to learn and this is one
of the things I trained intuitive
writers to do is how to take what they
see and feel and how to communicate it
in a very concise way and so that's just
one example I'm sure she learned a
million things I'm working with someone
like Vince Gilligan but that's just one
example she learned how to be very
concise in how she thought and felt and
pitched so the way that most writers get
here is they worked in TV for several
years with a really great showrunner and
through that process you learn these
skill sets and you adapt and you develop
or you just get pushed out or there's a
manager who will work intently with you
because the reality is most writers if
not all writers they have certain
strengths certain weaknesses and certain
blind spots blind spots or weaknesses
you don't know you have the key is to a
figure out what your blind spots are so
now that least they're known weaknesses
then how do you turn those weaknesses
into strengths and that's what that
dedicated practice comes in and it's
very difficult to do this yourself so a
manager who really knows what they're
doing they will develop right over you
know they'll take a writer who's really
good but not exceptional and they will
train that right over one two or three
years to do this and then when that
writer can write at that level they'll
go out with a script pretending that
that was the first thing the writer
wrote by definition when you sell
something that's the first script you
ever wrote you never talk about the rest
of it
so the writers that I know who have
career especially the best careers
generally speaking either they were
trained by showrunners because they were
able to work in TV early on or they were
trained by managers very few of them
were self trained it's possible I know
some examples but it took a decade and
and they're rare that they got there
well the reality is there are a lot of
writers who don't live in LA so they
can't work on the show and even if you
live in LA and you're like okay I'll
work on the show for training where do I
sign up it's not that easy it's very
competitive and the thing about managers
is they're so busy servicing their
clients no one wants to do development
anymore so the manager has to really
work with they're their top writers and
really help them develop their material
they don't have time to work with their
new writers their emerging writers so as
all these writers who are like having a
manager but they won't spend a lot of
time helping me and there's always
managers saying god I really wish I
could be helping these writers but I
don't have time so it's really hard to
find someone to do that kind of training
so that's when I used to teach at UCLA
for a long time I was and someone
challenged me this like can you develop
a training program to train writers like
this if they don't have a manager and do
this for them if they're not yet able to
get on a TV show or they don't want to
or they don't live in LA is there
another way they can learn these skill
sets because a lot of the the programs
out there they're just telling people to
take your writing and put it into this
paradigm but so what I did is I wanted
to create a series of workshops that
could teach these these new skills so
that's where this all came from I know
you'd said in another video that when
you were teaching at UCLA that each and
I'm forgive me if they're on the
semester system or the quarter system
but okay each quarter or semester you
would see maybe two people in the class
that you really felt were like the gem
and the gems and the other ones although
with time and with proper training they
could become that I'm wondering first of
all those two people that's hypothetical
would they really know could they see
that they were different from the other
writers good really okay how would they
know and what would they
how could they see it and how could you
see it so I was talking on us with a
manager the other day and I'm afraid I'm
going to over answer your question so I
apologize ahead of time so one of the
key skill sets in addition to creative
integration is to build the right and
compelling conflict and compelling
conflict is what takes great characters
and great dialogue and just makes it pop
off the page it's just it's hard to
explain that you have that you of a
visceral experience when you read you
can read you look you read some stuff
that's just bad and then you read some
stuff and it's got some great moments
and some great characters of dialogue
but it's messing really happening then
you read some stuff and it it's good
things are happening and it's
interesting but then you be something
just pops off the page it just you can
tell I was a studio reader and I could
tell within one page if someone knew
what they were doing if it popped off
the page or not now that one page was
great I don't know if they could write
out a whole script I have to keep
reading but if that one page didn't pop
I knew they couldn't and yeah if I had a
class of about 20 people there usually
about two people and their writing just
sort of popped off the page more than
others they even didn't know why
necessarily but everyone could tell and
I think they could tell they would often
not say anything it's like in a writing
group there's usually one person who's
writing just is better than everyone
else or an MFA program it's just maybe
people don't know why but it does
what I've learned is it's because
they're writing and compelling conflict
and I find that about 5% of the writers
that come to work with me naturally do
that I don't have to teach them it just
has that popping off the page and about
5% for to do that and the other 90% are
anywhere from they need some work today
they suck at it they just sucked at it
but you can keep people how to do it so
a great example is Neil Simon the
playwright he has a book called rewrites
which is his autobiography he talks
about like year after year when he was a
younger man he'd write these plays and
he loved the characters and in every one
thought they were sterically funny but
there was just something missing it just
didn't hold together this wasn't
interesting enough and over time he's
like I know something's missing
I don't know what it is and I know a lot
of writers who feel that way it's a
really terrible feeling he eventually
did the one thing he never wanted to do
is he went to his older brother who was
a really successful writer and his older
brother read his stuff and said you're
not writing a compelling conflict and
Neil Simon's like what are you talking
about what is this and he said my older
brother taught me what it was and then
the light bulb went off and so then he
said I would just structure my
compelling conflict and then pour in all
the character and comedy and that's how
he did his career David Mamet and this
was on my website or you can look online
he did a memo about a decade ago or so
to the writers of the unit his TV show
and he basically said you will learn how
to write in compelling conflict or
you'll be in the blinking unemployment
line or the bread line and a lot of
f-bombs in this memo but he's basically
saying this is not a natural skill set
for most people you will learn to do
this or you will not survive and so I
didn't know it at the time and and to go
back to your question actually that the
for the truth of my experience was the
eighteen people who stuff was in popping
off the page they weren't I wasn't able
to get them there and so I like a lot of
teachers and I talk teachers at UCLA and
other film schools and they'll say this
privately I don't know they'll say this
publicly it's like yeah when you teach a
class you're teaching for that one or
two person or people who have what it
takes the rest don't but let they have a
dream support them be encouraging don't
tell them that they don't have what it
takes
they'll figure it out and then when they
figure it out they will give up this
dream and they'll find the dream that
they have the talent for because not
everyone could be a real clash f91 could
be a professional athlete and so we
teach for that one or two that have what
it takes and for the rest we don't tell
them that they don't have what it takes
we could be wrong but they'll figure it
out and that's a real fixed mindset way
of approaching this and one of the books
that changed my life as a teacher is
mindset by Carol Dweck I make all of my
students read it's the only thing I make
them read she talks about the fixed
mindset in the growth mindset
and the growth mindset is okay these two
people who this does popping off the
page why what skills what talent today
how the other people don't have an the
growth mindset says talent is repeatable
skill sets and in maybe you're born with
them
maybe you develop them through nurture
and childhood or maybe you learn them as
an adult it doesn't matter how you
acquire them it's just a skill set
that's repeatable as opposed to luck so
repeatable skill set is you know you
learn how to drive a car you can drive
me now you can always drive a car right
a bike and so they have the people that
pop off the page they have certain skill
sets certain tools that other people
don't you can figure out what those are
compelling conflict and then you can
start how to teach compelling conflict
then you can teach those skill sets to
other people and they can learn that
talent and with so I I have I had a
writer that kind Kang to me his name's
Gary and he had a manager and he was
always taking meetings but he could
never sell anything you can never get
hired he felt like he was that close to
a career for five years and then at some
point you're like okay this something's
not here something's not working so he
came to me deeply into it a writer that
he wrote the most amazing characters in
dialogue I didn't all I taught him on
that front was don't change what you're
doing he knows like you're amazing just
keep doing that
don't let anyone interfere with that but
on the conceptual side you've got some
real weaknesses and him specifically was
escalation how to keep making things get
strong like keep making things worse and
worse in an organic way that was his so
he was an easy case in that he had
everything but one skill set he was
really missing one skill set so I gave
him those training exercises and then
unbeknownst to me when I was done with
that class he spent the next three
months doing those training exercises
every day for four hours I didn't know
that that's a growth mindset guy that's
a guy who's like I want to become an
expert
at this skill set that I naturally am
terrible at and at the end of those
three months he was as good at that as a
natural conceptual writer is good at
that he was just as good at that as
anyone he now has a movie coming at I
think it's released in the fall starring
um or what's her name anyway not Reese
Witherspoon but someone like anyway he
has a movie that that come out yes came
at the agents he sold to TV pilots and
he had everything but that one skill set
now at the same time I've worked with
writers who are graded escalations and
great at big concepts but their
characters and dialogue it's just like
these are puppets and through the
intuitive training they could come off
the other end where their characters and
dialogue are just as good as these
people who are naturally great so the
key is you have natural talents and then
there's talent that you don't have or
you're not that strong yet if you train
the right way you can if you're willing
to put the time and effort in the right
way you can end up being just as
talented as someone who's naturally that
way and that's the growth mindset so for
years I honestly and I'm embarrassed to
say this but for years I would teach a
class and I'd come home and I'd say how
it goes I go these two people I think
could have careers the rest of them not
so much and over time usually those two
people would go on and have careers and
none of the others and I'm like well I
teach for those two people I encourage
everyone else because you never know but
probably going to find out they don't
have what it takes when I change this
approach and it took a long time l
effort I remember I had a class where
there it was only ten people there was
one person who you could tell how to
take the other nine know and within four
years one of those nine people dropped
out because of long story so that left
eight and of that eight six of them went
on to got careers and I wasn't a smarter
or more dynamic or I wasn't a better
teacher than prior I just had a
different teaching approach and it was
the approach that was radically
different until creative integration
skillset saying approach so
it took me years and a lot of help from
other people I didn't just invent all
this myself but that's the really cool
thing about talent and is that it's
repeatable skill sets and you can learn
these skill sets and you can develop
them if you know how to train yourself
and you want to put the time and energy
into it let's talk about this
hypothetical class of twenty people two
excellent people that you think have
potential to have careers and the
eighteen that don't do you think those
eighteen people want to hear the truth
knowing that they can be it's malleable
they can you know sort of you can mold
them too but do they really want to hear
it and talk about this growth mindset
versus what's the other side of that
coin which is fix my exam okay and so
how do you know you're experiencing a
student that has the fixed mindset offer
and they don't want to hear it perfect
perfect perfect question that is such a
smart question so the fixed mindset
first of all believes that if you want
to be a writer you have this talent or
you don't so then it's you are
constantly have this voice in your head
that says do I have what it takes do I
have the talent am I wasting my time am
I going to get a career or is it never
going to happen for me
that constant cheer base fear-based
chatter is that fixed mindset and
because of that the fixed mindset and
you have such a smart question
it desires an outcome so if I have a
script and I go hey will you guys read
my script and just give me your feedback
I'll know what you think there's the
fixed mindset in the growth mindset and
they're both there I don't think it's
one or the other I think they both exist
it's just sort of a ratio are you 90
percent growth mindset and ten percent
fixed or divisor when I give you guys a
script it goes tell me what you think my
fixed mindset wants an outcome it wants
you to to say well now I know why you
had a career now I know why you teach
others this is maybe the best script
I've ever read I am I'm literally in awe
to be in the same room with you I didn't
know human being could Isis this well
this is this was the most amazing script
ever like that's what my fixed mindset
wants to hear
and when it doesn't hear it it's going
to throw a temper tantrum and at that
point it has two choices and only two
choices which is what's wrong with you
guys or what's wrong with me so you
always hear writers out there saying
yeah my manager said that the characters
weren't strong enough you know I got
changed managers I mean he doesn't know
what he's talking about
or they'll say yeah the manager said the
characters weren't good enough I don't I
don't know why I know good at characters
because something wrong with you or
something wrong with me the only choice
is that it has the growth mindset does
not crave or desire an outcome it
desires the truth so the growth mindset
wants to know what did you honestly
think and why did you think it and let's
say that there are parts of my script
that you really loved and there was a
section of the script that you just
didn't care for why and not in a
defensive way and not in an attacking
way but why because it's like a
detective it's like hmm what plays in my
head is amazing it's not amazing for you
I want to know why where is that
disconnect maybe there is a piece of
information there context that I knew
that you didn't I didn't get out well
enough and if I could just rewrite it so
that becomes more viscerally clear to
people maybe you'll then have the
experience along maybe that section I
like it for very personal reasons but it
actually disconnects from this there's a
whole million reasons but if I and maybe
maybe the reason you didn't love my
script the honest truth is the
characters just weren't compelling
enough for you they felt kind of flat
they felt kind of like they all spoke
the same way
that's not now a rewrite which is the
mistake most you'll make that is okay
I'm not yet strong enough at characters
or the story the characters great but it
kind of wandered around and it just it
just didn't seem like it had a forward
thrust and maybe I'm just not good at
that forward thrust great the growth the
fixed mindset of course is freaking out
but the growth mindset is celebrating
because it's like okay now I know what I
can do
be moving forward to get better as a
writer now I got to figure out how do I
train myself to get better at forward
thrust or soul or better at characters
and so if you follow a growth mindset
when you get feedback if you love my
script top to bottom and I know the
process that I use to create it and I
can replicate that process that is great
news for me if you didn't love my script
top to bottom and I can talk to you in
the right way to figure out why you did
it where the disconnects were and I
could realize where I have a weakness
where I need to get better at a skill
set where I need to create a new talent
or get better at a talent and I can
figure out how to do it that's amazing
so the growth mindset is not looking for
an outcome it's looking for the truth so
your question was really profound those
18 people did they want to know that
they are in 18 people if you ask them
they all say yes the reality is if you
were to tell them and I never did I
never that was for right or wrong
reasons that was a line I would never
cross I would never tell someone if I
thought they had what it took or didn't
I just didn't want it because I felt
like that's just my opinion what is my
opinion worth at the end of the day and
I don't want to inflict that on someone
positively or negatively so I don't know
I'm not saying this wisdom of the right
decision but as a teacher to this day if
someone says do you think I have what it
takes around well first of all say go
read mind set because that's a fixed
mindset question but even if I actually
have an opinion I'll never tell someone
anyway but if I if someone were to tell
those people the they would say I want
to know the truth and that is true for
their growth mindset but their fixed
mindset does not want to know the truth
it wants an answer it wants a specific
answer it won't say yes or the fixed
mindset would be okay with I don't think
you have what it takes but I don't think
it will take that long for you to get
there the six mindsets like
oh all right I'll settle for that but
anything beyond that and then the fixed
mindset it's like well what do you know
or yeah I don't you know so and the
reality is what I've learned is that we
are always both fixed mindset and growth
mindset and if you really do the work
you can feel you know kind of the ratios
and in fact like people often ask me why
I teach and there's a lot of answers but
I'll tell you one of the main reasons
that I do this is as a writer I had a
very unhealthy relationship with my
writing it was really torturous
experience because as a writer I was
about as fixed mindset as you could be
as a teacher I'm about as growth mindset
as you can be so for some reason
teaching is that one space in my life
where it is just so easy to be egoless
and growth mindset and you know for
other people maybe that's religion or
parenting or whatever for me it's
teaching not sure why but it is and I
didn't even know about mindset at the
time that's something I learned later on
a brilliant student said hey you should
read this book I think and I was like oh
my god where's has been my whole life
and but yeah so for me teaching I'm
sorry writing had all these demons and
and anxiety and fears and it was just as
I was was a very angry person and it was
either what the f is wrong with my agent
or this executive and this and just or
what is wrong with me
and that was a my only two choices and
as a teacher it allows me to live in a
growth mindset place and to be a much
it's very healing for me and it's just I
get so much out of that and then I
really love working with writers and
really helping them find and stay in
that growth mindset because that is so
important to a writer Cory from your
time at film school and also you know
having writing instructors talk to you
when you were in college did you feel
embraced or discouraged some thinking
about like a Ray Bradbury interview I
saw
he said he advised a lot of people not
to to take writing classes because he
felt that they were always discouraged
um how do you feel as a student really
encouraged teaching okay but that's
actually why I would have people think
twice about taking those classes because
there's fixed mindset encouragement and
there's growth mindset encouragement and
so you know the very first teacher that
I let me said that a lot of teachers
that I know have a philosophy that the
more you write the better you'll become
and so they're in job is to encourage
writers and yeah I mean you you're going
to point out things are not doing right
you're going to criticize you're going
to but you always couch that with three
compliments you know like that's the
sugar with the medicine and also the
other day your job is to make these
people feel like they can do this that
they have what it takes and I'll see
some writing and the more they write the
better it'll become and I don't I don't
do that as a teacher for a variety of
reasons first as I said I think most
writers when they first start writing
they see significant improvement because
when we first start writing we make lots
of really dumb mistakes that we don't
know we don't know what we don't know so
if you're if you're somewhat open to
feedback and criticism you're trying to
get better and you have reasonably smart
or really smart people in your life
reading your stuff and giving you
feedback I do think people really start
to make a real improvement then they hit
a plateau they'll stay on forever and
that plateau is where the more they
write the more the higher the pile of
some early flawed scripts are because if
they have intuitive weaknesses or
conceptual weaknesses you can keep
writing as much as you want you're just
going to keep making those mistakes so I
don't believe I know writers who've been
on it for 10 or 12 years and what
they're writing today isn't really any
better than what they're writing eight
years ago so I don't believe I believe
the more you write the better you become
without the right training and tools is
for most people kind of a Santa Clause
Tooth Fairy fantasy further I do think
it's really important to have someone in
your life for people right who who
believe in you and love you and support
you and when you're feeling down they're
like no you can do this and they can be
the wind in your sails when the wind you
know goes away and you're just sort of
loose
confidence and you lose your way I think
that's absolutely essential I would
never do that as a teacher I don't think
someone should pay for that and also I
don't want something to become dependent
on me so I want them to find people in
their lives and ultimately themselves to
be able to have that you know confidence
in love and the further I think that the
six mindset confidence is always point
out what you're doing right and
complimenting it you're so good you're
so good you have what it takes that's so
fix mindset I think the growth mindset
is there's tools that you can learn and
let me teach you a tool and so let like
what is your biggest weakness as a
writer let's spend four weeks doing
nothing but training on that tool and
then we're going to have you write a
scene or a sequence and you're going to
see and or you give to other people and
they're going to see oh my god you're
you're suddenly better at this thing and
then you're like oh that's the
confidence I want to give someone I had
a weakness identified it or it was
identified for me I had a specific
training regimen I came out the other
end stronger at that and maybe you're
not as strong as you need to be yet but
you can keep training and you can keep
training and you realize I can get to
the point where I'm as good as I need to
be okay now Andy I've got six other
things I need to do that on and so maybe
it can take six months or a year that's
growth mindset confidence that's what I
want to instill in people so my
experience for the most part in film
school was very gentle everyone came in
and told us you can make this you can do
this you're amazing and in my class
there were 12 of us three of us went on
to have careers and nine didn't and one
thing that the three of us had in common
we weren't smarter than the I certainly
wasn't smarter than some of the others
or a lot of the others we didn't work
harder honestly I didn't work that hard
in film school I'm not proud of that but
I had a lot of procrastination issues
what we did have in common is we all had
a manager not to saying that everybody
all had a manager who in their own way
said you're not as good as you think you
are and you need to get better in
certain skill sets and I can help you do
that and in my case it was a year of
looking with this manager turning
weaknesses that I didn't know I had or I
did know I had into strength that's a
big reason why I teach because I had
access to that if I didn't I would have
been like the nine who didn't I mean I I
had certain things I was inherently
really good at and I had certain things
I was inherently really bad at and I had
things I didn't know I was bad at and no
one in film school was really helping me
with that it was it was the manager who
did that work so I I think yeah classes
where they just sort of tear you down
and discourage you should be avoided at
all costs I know people who have
troubles with their writing and they
don't feel confident and they find the
teacher that gives them confidence and
support and they love that teacher and
they become addicted to that teacher and
they'll take and it's a good business
model for the teacher because they'll
keep taking classes because they're
taking classes to feel that feeling
right but that's not solving the problem
if I can make you feel confident or good
about your writing or special I can make
you feel like you can get there that
doesn't mean anything what matters is
when you can feel that way and the way
you'll feel that way in my opinion is
through proving to yourself that you're
making progress and confidence through
your training so it sounds like this
sort of military style you know boot
camp breaking you down is going to harm
someone or the same then too much
hand-holding and babying and oh you're
one of our prize you know that sounds
like that's also damaging like that I
think there's I think highly addicting
but it's not getting any better feeling
good but that was like junk food she'll
be good but it's not nutritious it's not
making you healthier so I'm wondering
with this manager do you think you were
more open to hearing then than some of
the other people I mean I mean if you
say that you feel that you were on the
same level right right well there a
difference that you were maybe mother
great that's a great question and as I
said earlier I was such an incredibly
fixed mindset person so I was absolutely
not open to here I mean I got very lucky
so this is what happen and I want to
share this because I try to share as
many writers as I can because I think
this is a really important story and
there's some
being here that they can do which I
would highly recommend so what happened
is I wrote this script and the story of
the manager was that I was in a writing
group and there were some professional
writers there's actually Academy Award
nominated writer we met at her house so
I was really exciting and I had written
the script they were giving me feedback
and long story short it got to the point
where they're like this scripts amazing
this script will sell the only question
is how much it will sell for do you want
help getting an agent and of course that
was like magic to my ears and then I
mentioned this to my professor at UCLA
who you know a lot of really big writers
had come through that school and through
his class and so he volunteered to read
the script and you know this is one of
the three best scripts I've ever read in
20 years at UCLA and again I'm thinking
of all these amazing writers that so I'm
like well I guess I'm as good as those
and he goes this will definitely sell
you want help in getting the manager an
agent and I was interning for a manager
at the time just as an intern so as a
favor as a favor to that manager I'm
like do you want to read this because I
like it's going to sell it gee what do
you want your 10% or not buddy and so he
agreed to read it took like three weeks
which told me crazy and then we had a
meeting I'll never forget I go in there
and he's like this is a pretty good
rough draft don't show it to in the
industry because when you show stuff to
people industry they get coverage
reports on it and those are database
that's your first impression but if it's
not great coverage you haven't just
blown your chances at that production
company they're going to share that
coverage with everybody so database so
you you blown your first impression
across the board and he said this will
not serve you well but you have some
real strengths you have some real
weaknesses you have you know some blind
spots I could help you with that if your
was giving me this old talk and the
whole time I'm like what is wrong with
it and like did I tell you what the
Academy award-nominated person's I say
it my professor who represented Stevens
or you know top Stevens it wasn't slate
you know and he said look they were all
telling you the truth this is a better
script in most scripts it's an
impressive script but it's not nearly as
good as what you need in the industry
you look your people on the writing
group are working writers
your professor at UCLA all smart people
but they're not in the business of
breaking writers into the business I am
I know how good something has to be this
isn't closed
and I'm like didn't want to believe that
my fixed mindsets like he's an idiot and
so what he said and all this was the
best thing anybody could have said is
hire three studio readers pay them under
the table
if this script came through the tracking
system what coverage would you write and
then give me the coverage the honest
coverage and the coverage isn't good
it's not going to hurt you because it's
just you only see it nobody else sees it
and I'd have a lot of money but I did
this I paid him like 100 hundred fifty
bucks three different people someone had
imagined someone at Warner Brothers and
so when it Scott Rudin's company and the
coverage came back and it wasn't
terrible and it wasn't bad it was okay
which is terrible it would have hurt me
it was clear that his coverage was like
this is okay not being special nothing
great here and then on the writer it
says you know recommend consider it was
low marks on the writing on two of the
three and that you can't hide from that
and then the manager said I'll work with
you if you're willing to put your ego at
the door and do this training so I did
and it was like 14 months it was
grueling he was he was not a good person
but that his training was good it was it
was marine it was much rougher than it
had to be but okay and at the end of
that time he said I now think the script
is where it needs to be all pay for
coverage reports and he paid for three
coverage reports of three different
people real actual readers and it was
all just exactly what you want
exceptional coverage and literally three
weeks later Ridley Scott hires me to
write metropolis eye flies me to London
I mean like my whole world changed my
whole life changed and it never would
have happened if that manager hadn't
sort of forced me to pay for coverage
and so because at some point it takes
mindset
hide and that's what I always tell
people if you're thinking they the
biggest mistake you can make is go out
to the marketplace before you're ready
and just because your friends think it's
great and just because your teacher
thinks it's great and just because the
script consultant you hired is great and
I I don't do anymore I used to do script
consulting but I say don't listen to
those people because they often they're
running a business in a business want
happy repeat customer so they often tell
you what you want to hear and even if
you find the script consultant has
incredible integrity which is rare but
they exist they're not in the business
of breaking writers into the business
and and I wouldn't listen to their
advice per se I know people who are like
I had the script consultant said this
this and this I went out to the
marketplace look at the coverage it
stunk it happens all the time
I say hire actual readers under the
table in TV or feature wherever you are
and get the actual coverage report that
they would get and if all three coverage
reports come back recommend recommend
highest marks then you're ready to go up
then then yeah get on the highest
mountain pound your chest and get
everybody to read your script if that's
not the case stay off the radar you
don't want people reading your material
it's going to hurt you and figure out
how you can train yourself to get better
so sorry for a long answer but no I was
very fixed mindset and if that manager
hadn't done that for me I'd be taking
classes a day I wouldn't be teaching
them core let's talk about someone who
has an agent and two scenarios either
they've been dropped by their agents and
I don't know how you would be dropping B
via email telephone call and on the flip
side those who feel that they should
drop their agent so two scenarios well
the second one's hard because of course
the question is why do you want to drop
your agent and it's usually because
they're not working for me and they're
not doing what they're supposed to be
doing and I'd have a career or better
career if they were well the challenge
you're in a really tough spot because if
you're going to try to find another
agent they're going to know it's sort of
like trying to find a wife but you're
married right so they know you're
married to someone so then the question
is why are you leaving your wife and why
do you want a new life and then because
if the writers start saying well my age
is not doing this
not paying attention to me everyone in
towns going to say you're blaming your
agent but it's you and your writing is
not good enough and and oh yeah I want
to say I'm a super busy agent what I
want to do is take a client who's not
that good who always blames their agent
also as an agent you know what I love is
spending time and energy on someone
who's not loyal to me so yeah let me
jump in business with you when you have
an agent and you want to switch agents
like that's the hardest place to be and
if you really are there first of all
just stop and and the question becomes
imagine that there is a factory that's
polluting a river and then down river
all these kids are getting really sick
and Doctors Without Borders flies into
that village and they start working with
those kids giving them medicines and
treatments to help those kids get sown
Doctors Without Borders doing a great
thing but they're running in a circle
because they can't they're not fixing
the problem they're fixing the
consequence of the problem the only way
to fix the problem is to stop the
factory from polluting or get a
different water source for the village
so the question is is the problem that
your agent isn't working for you
probably not that's probably the sick
kids
what's the factory so if I'm with that
writer let's sit down and talk about why
your agents not working for you because
in a day an agent is a salesperson and
an agent is selling writers and material
and they have only so much time and
energy so they're going to prioritize on
the ones that can sell so if the means
your agent is not prioritizing for you
why not and nine out of ten times the
problem isn't the agent the problem is
with you or your writing and if you
don't realize that and work on that you
can try to switch agents as long as you
want all that's going to happen you're
going to reputation of someone who
blames everyone else and is it loyal and
you're going to be in a really bad shape
now is it possible that just something
happened to your agent and there's
nothing to do with you
it's possible but it's very unlikely
let's say that's the case I don't think
you as a writer should be trying to
change agents you need to find the
intermediary so you're going that's why
you have a manager or an entertainment
lawyer but that's why you owe everyone
has a manager today so if your agents
not working
for you you talk to your manager and
your manager will tell you it's your
fault Chuck this is what you need to be
doing or if it's something with the
agent then the manager can talk to
another agent and sort of put the thing
in that you might want to try to steal
this person but you don't want to be out
there doing it
okay so let's suppose you get the call
or the email that you've been dropped
what do you do well because I believe in
working with rioters is when something
like that happen I believe that you
should give yourself a 24 hour fixed
mindset pity party because like when you
try to say growth mindset and it's so
exhausting when you're pushing
everything down so scream cry drink yell
blame your mom blame your dad blame your
a blame your cat I mean 24 hours just
have your meltdown but then then in 24
hours that's done spend those 24 hours
wisely now it's time to go to a growth
mindset and now what you want to know is
why they dropped you and you may not be
able to find out because agents won't
always tell you the truth it'll depend
on the agent in your relationship again
you probably have an agent and a manager
and the manager should be able to tell
the truth and the manager won't tell you
the truth probably not the best manager
for you so you try to figure out the
truth and if you could figure out the
truth then that will lead you to what
you want to do about it
but if I can step back for a second I
love my agent I think he's the best
agent in the world
I'm RuPt abrupt at WME there was another
agent WME who I think of the second best
agent I rolled their names Audrianna
Alba Getty and she said something once
they think it's so important for writers
to hear she said that some writers get
it and some writers don't get it and the
writers who get it are all working and
the writers who don't get it most of
them aren't working and so as an agent
she just wants to work with writers who
get it and this is what it is a lot of
writers think that you know to write a
script that changes your life to write a
script that gets you your first job or
to get really Scott to hire you or to
get a whatever it is you're
aspiring to you have a career we're
trying to take
to the next level they think it's about
writing having the right script at the
right time at the right place that's not
it
that's a mistake that surrenders all
control and power to the universe the
reality is your job is to think in six
script cycles and you have to be writing
the right kinds of scripts pitch perfect
authentic we talked about that earlier
and let's assume you trained yourself
that still to do that you need to write
six of those every two years and the
reason is if you write six of these
pitch perfect authentic scripts one of
them is going to go out to the
marketplace and just fizzle and you'll
never know why and then two or three of
them will go out and they'll start to
get some traction but then something
will happen in Darrell it and then
they'll be one or two that's absolutely
going to happen you have the director
tasks you have the stars there's a
bidding war there's no way it's not
going to happen and something is a very
left second is going to derail it and
one of the six will actually go the
distance and sell or it'll be that
script that gets you the next three or
four years of getting staffs on show
there'll be one of those six scripts
that will just catch lightning in a
bottle one of those six you don't know
which one it'll be so if you're not
working right now you ought to be
writing three or four of these scripts a
year because you're thinking and six
script cycles so any one script goes out
and ultimately doesn't do what you need
to do you don't feel like a victim
that's one of six this is the key if you
are working you have two jobs now you
have your day job and your weekend night
job so if your day job is a feature
assignment for Ridley Scott or your day
job is you just got staffed on Jane the
virgin one of my students just as I keep
saying stressed out she's very excited
you have to do everything you have to
that you have to excel at that job but
then at night so we can you got to be
writing pitch perfect authentic scripts
and maybe you're not writing three or
four a year maybe you're writing - a
year because but you don't stop writing
these scripts and creating these scripts
because one of these scripts is going to
be the thing that takes your career to
the next level and so the writers that
don't get it is I'm working I'm making
money I've made it
Disney it's like I have a family I am
writing there's no other time and I get
that but the reality is the writers that
get it even though they're working
they're still always creating these new
material and they think about it in six
script cycles and so a lot of times
agents drop the writers who aren't doing
that and you know I get it because like
when I was a working studio writer I
wasn't continued to write the scripts I
was just doing my Studios assignment
work and I was making good money and I
was really I was too busy I didn't want
to do that
my agent kept telling me to do this I
didn't and he said at some point your
writing career is going to end badly and
I worked non-stop for 11 years but I was
a working writer but I never became an
a-list writer and the only way I could
have become an a-list writer is to keep
writing the script so there was another
writer Erik singer who wrote a script
and he started getting all these studio
assignments and he was making a lot of
money but he kept writing on his own
time he's pitch perfect authentic scrap
year after year after year and
eventually one of them hit and it was
American hustle and so he's now suddenly
a huge writer I know the guys that wrote
the NIC same thing you know they're
their staff writers and they were making
really good money but they were writing
stuff that they really believed in and
the Nick was one of them and that's that
script just took them to a whole other
level Alan Ball it's American Beauty we
could go on and on and on so often
agents drop writers who might be really
great writers but they don't get it they
don't keep creating this new absolute so
it's either they don't keep creating
material or they're not creating the
right kind of ensure it's not good
enough I have a lot of friends or agents
and if you keep creating the right kind
of content even when you're working and
in the contents amazing and you play
well with others it's very unlikely
they're going to drop you because that's
exactly the kind of person they want to
represent and in that case if they drop
you it
it could be a conflict of their client
it could be a lot of things have nothing
to do with you but if you're not doing
all of those things and an agent drops
you then you have to look in the mirror
okay so the time of this interview is
we're in 2017 is it better for a
screenwriter to focus on spec
screenplays or a spec television pilot
so I think that TV writing and feature
film writing are different art forms
there's a lot of overlap but they're
very different so I think that someone
has to first of all say do I want to be
a feature film writer or don't want to
be a TV writer now it's possibly
possible they want to do both but
generally writers have a preference to
one or the other now that said there is
so much more opportunity and money in TV
than there is in feature features are
getting better but not as good although
I know a lot of TV writers who are
sneaking over to the future'
neighborhood because a lot less
competition but that said I do have
clients and students who want to be
feature film writers but want to become
TV writers as their day jobs while they
keep writing their moonlight or their
Manchester by the sea or whatever
they're writing but what I would say is
you know there's this training of all
the creative integration and skill sets
and then when you really get to that the
last train of really designing and
executing on your stories and your
characters it's there's different
training for TV or feature so I would
say if someone is sort of new to this
whole game I pick one of those forms and
really get strong at that before you try
to learn the other I wouldn't be
bouncing back and forth because then you
kind of become kind of good but not
grated either
now if someone's really great at one
form yeah focus on the other so it is
really hard to sell a feature film
original script but it's getting a
little bit easier which means it's gone
from impossible to almost impossible a
little bit it I ain't I have in the last
two months I've had four four students
sell feature scrubs and so it is
certainly possible but you see more
action on the
TV side but I think the mistake a lot of
people make is they want to go buy a TV
script cuz they think there's more
action and it's easier but their hearts
not really into it they don't really
want to be a TV writer it's not really
trained to be a TV writer and they're
wasting their time so I maybe I'm a
romantic but I just think that there's
going to be so much training and so much
dedication and sacrifice to get into the
business and and what people don't
understand is that getting in the
business as hard as that is is a lot
easier than staying in the business and
if you're going to go through all of
that then do it for a career that you
want do it for a life that you want
I mean TV writing and feature film
writing is very different I was the
future phone writer for 11 years I had
total control of my schedule I would
take meetings maybe one or two maybe one
or two days a week but only when I
wanted to most the time I I could be in
Europe writing I could be here writing I
could do what I had so much control over
my schedule I would work really intently
on something for three or four months
and I could take two months off TV
writing is very different you're going
to be working maybe eight nine months
intensely and then you get time off
you're going to be working in a room a
lot with other people
some people love that some people hate
that there's a lot more politics that
can go in the TV writing some people can
thrive in that some people hate that
now teacher phone later I would
constantly be writing scripts pouring
heart and soul into something ever got
made and I friend a friend who was a
writer on that man and she would write
something and then you know a few months
later we could watch it and I was so
jealous of that she was so jealous that
I did my work literally in Paris
for two months at one time she was very
jealous of that so I would say like
think about your life I think what I
always tell writers is if I couldn't
guarantee you success writing for movies
or TV which would you pick and whichever
one you pick if I could guarantee you
success writing any kind of thing you
know any kind of TV show comedy drama or
a movie what would you pick and then
work backwards from there to see what
kind of spec
scripts you should be writing and so how
about vision for what kind of career you
want what kind of life you want work
backwards and write those kinds of
scripts and that's plan a and hopefully
final work now over enough period of
time it's high na is not working you can
consider Plan B Plan B is would be the
easier script to sell where where's the
market plate how do i game the
marketplace that doesn't set you up for
the life you want or the career you want
that's just I want an agent I want to
sell something the mistake that I made
that I help others don't make is plan D
was my plan a I was in film school and I
said eh I heard the story how Jim Carrey
and I'll know this is true or not the
struggling comic and he said someone
told him to do this he wrote a check to
himself for 1 million dollars and he
post dated a year later and he said in
one year I'm gonna go to cash this
cheque and within one year he got living
color and he made millions of dollars is
that a true story I don't know I hope so
I don't know but I was 23 years old when
I heard it so I thought it was a true
story so I didn't write my I was I
started by a check but it was I just
couldn't do that but I did write in my
calendar one year later I will have an
agent and I will have sold the script I
wrote that in that account I told
everyone a year from now I'm going to do
that so my when we were walking we moved
in the direction of where we're looking
that's our intent
so that was my intent in one year I'll
have an agent in solo scope and it was
actually 13 months later so I didn't
quite make it I had an agent
I actually didn't sell a script but I
sold a pitch to Ridley Scott and he flew
me to London and was on the front page
of variety so I was willing to call that
a success okay and what I realized as
after I finished metropolis and was on
the front page variety Ridley was going
to make it and he said very positive
things about the script and me I was
named on the front page of variety made
my mom's day and something I was a hot
writer in town and I was getting all
these job offers and I remember thinking
all these offers that I'm getting are
four kinds of things I don't really want
to be writing so I called mange and I'm
like I don't want to be writing those
kind of things I'm so stupid I'm like
I'll be writing these kind of things so
get me those kind of offers and I forget
what she said she said it's such a
polite classy
Martin woman but she basically said you
idiot if you wanted to be doing this why
did you write this script in the trolley
everything you wrote lines you up for
this career if you don't want this
career and you want that career why did
you write those scripts why did you sell
metropolis and the honest answer is
because I was just trying to get an
agent and sell something I hadn't
thought I was 24 years old I didn't I
was so fixed mindset I said if I can't
sell a script in a year I'm going to law
school because if I don't sell the
script in a year means I don't have what
it takes
which is very fixed mindset and very
stupid and so I tell people don't make
the mistake I made
Plan B is okay I just want to get an
agent just want to sell something I just
want to validate I can do that's the
plan a is what career do I want what
life do I want and reverse engineer but
you should be writing to give yourself
to that you mentioned being the hot
young writer you know being on the front
page of variety your names out there
you're probably your phone's ringing and
I know you you've talked in other
interviews about how some of that went
away for a little bit can you talk about
if someone else is in a similar
situation how they regroup yeah what I'd
like to do is give the single best piece
of advice that I ever got that I ignored
and so what happened is when I was in
the front page a variety and all these
offers were coming in there was an agent
at my agency Barbra Dreyfus who didn't
represent me but she took me out to
lunch and she gave me the following
advice she said the next script you
write is the most important trip she'll
ever write it will determine the
trajectory of your career
so right now you were an unknown person
now you're on everyone's radar he worked
as a high profile director he's planning
on making the movie he said how great
your script was everybody in town wants
to work with you so everyone is like so
hyped up on you now there are writers
who are commodity writers they go in and
they write these big summer movies these
big good action movies
make a lot of money but there's nothing
special about them then there's writers
who are ALS writers writers who have
these amazing careers the next script
you write will put you on a trajectory
so her advice was this don't take any
job that you wouldn't have done for free
which is to say you love this project
and you believe you could just knock it
out of the park you love this so much
you would do it without getting paid now
we're going to get you paid but don't
take anything that falls short of that
and you'll have to say no to a lot of
stuff because most of what they're going
to offer you is crap or just not a good
fit for you and the offers will start to
slow down and you're going to panic and
think you have to grab the next best one
don't and the offers will keep slowing
down and I'm telling you this that even
you'll think the offers will eventually
go away and they won't but even if they
do literally you've said no to
everything spec your next script and
make it something that you love and
knock it out of the park because she
said if the next one is amazing and that
puts you on a trajectory that then
people see with certainly later on is
the time to do it for the money later on
we'll grab a lot of money but right now
this next script that you're on now
everyone knows who you are
this next script is going to tell them
what kind of writer you are and when she
said that I had that chill up my spine
that this is absolutely true I need to
hear this and do this and I said no to
something I said no to something the
third time I said no is a Disney project
and they doubled my quotes and I said no
and they doubled my quote and I said yes
and I'm embarrassed to say that that
project of all the projects was not only
a script I didn't want to write it was a
movie I wouldn't even want to see but it
was sudden I don't come from money I had
student debt and it was more money than
I ever thought you could make in years
and I was going to get paid for three
months and so the precedent that I set I
think with myself at that point is I'm
in this for the money
and and I and that really locked me into
a career path and it was I wish I could
go back in time I feel like that was a
really big test
and I failed it I I could see where a
lot of people would not blame you I'm
not even sure which project you're
referring to forgive me but I mean so
you really feel like even the money that
you took and probably it changed many
things for you because money money can
do wonderful things it can also hurt but
I mean but here's the thing if I hadn't
taken that project and that project
never got made and you know as a writing
sample I think it was it was good but it
wasn't special I'd waited and waited and
took something else or even to something
original and if it was great I would
have made so much more money down the
road Delma I mean so you know my agent
you know represents me but he also
represents Aaron Sorkin I worked
non-stop as a studio writer for eleven
years I made a lot more money never
thought I could make you know the
difference between how much money Aaron
Sorkin is me I don't know but I can I'm
sure that what Aaron Sorkin makes is not
even in the same zip code is what I made
he also represents JK Rowling now I'm
not saying that I could have become
Aaron Sorkin or that level or I could
have been JK Rowling I don't know but
what I do know is that the choices I
made prevented that from being a
possibility I was a studio writer I just
kept doing a bunch of action movies and
summer action comedy movies sometimes I
thought they were fun sometimes I didn't
but I loved the paycheck and I loved
just making the money and the deal and I
never stopped and wrote from my heart I
never wrote and I'll tell you one of the
main reasons is I was so fixed mindset I
was so afraid of rejection I was so
afraid that every script I wrote I was
afraid that people would say oh you're
not that good of a writer you're a fraud
now if I wrote something from my heart
if I wrote something that was authentic
that exposed me into the material now
they could say you're not a good writer
and you're not even a good person like
they could reject me if they rejected my
material and it was very personal and
that was like they were rejecting me as
a person and that was too painful I was
not going to allow it happen you might
agent was begging me to write something
authentic and from there my wife was
dead giving me my manager was begging me
my golden retriever was begging me and I
just wouldn't and so it's just it's just
a it was short-sighted
first of all money isn't everything but
even if money is everything I
potentially could have made so much more
money but more importantly I could have
written stuff that I was in love with
and I could have look maybe I would have
I could have tried for that career I
could have written authentic stuff I
could have swung for the fences I could
have tried for that a-list career and
maybe come up short and and then back in
the career I had maybe there's no I
don't know but I know that the choices I
made meant I was never going to have
that career I was never going to be
creatively fulfilled I was never going
to write the stuff that I really want to
be writing I was never going to writing
from love I was always been writing from
fear
I regret that and so part of the reason
I teaches I want to help writers do it
the right way and help empower them with
the tool I wish someone taught me
creative integration up front and some
of the stuff but I hope that I can be an
influence on writers so that they can
have the best possible career that
they're capable of and maybe even a
better one than that so if you were to
take yourself to lunch that is that
woman in that way was it was an older
you talking to that younger you would
you say the exact same thing I would
have a little and I would have said and
look I'm from the future so let me tell
you and I would I would have told them
all the terrible things that happened
and I honestly think that that younger
me would have made the same decision and
the reason is if he he was so fixed
mindset and takes mindset you're just
working from fear and you just can't see
the truth or you can't
and hopefully that's not true hopefully
I would've but anyway I'm not confident
that I would have made a different
decision I'm not proud of that but I
think that's the truth but I will say
you know one of the things I like my
knife always sees like the real truth
and you know one of the things she says
like all of things happen in my career
is actually a blessing I mean it
softened me up it got me out of this
fear space and and I wouldn't be the
teacher that I am now had I not made
those mistakes and gone through that and
I did make a lot of money which is nice
so it's like you know it it had a lot of
perks but yeah I wish I could have done
it differently
so you've worked with a lot of young
students and I'm curious what the the
idea in their minds of what it's like
out in the real world is versus what the
real world is like in terms of whether
they were the two best writers in the
whole class well I think you know when I
teach a class that UCLA or my private
workshops there's all these people that
just want to be professional writers I
have no idea what it's like to be a
professional writer and I don't think
you ever know until you do it and so
it's just I want to be a freshman writer
and I have a vision of what that would
be I think most people's vision is I sit
in a room or in a room with other people
but let's say I sit in a room and I
write what I want to write and I write
it in a way that I want to write it and
I write what I love and everyone else
will love it it don't work the Helly
people have a process to how they write
and that process usually is what's
comfortable because it plays their
strengths and hides a weaknesses and
it's learning how to write in a way that
other people love it as much as you love
it and it takes a lot of work and a lot
of training and then there's deadlines
and there's politics it's there's a lot
that goes into having a writing career
beyond just the writing I mean the
reality was like you have two careers
you have the writing you know you have
you have to create the content but then
there's the Career Management and the me
and the marketing and always be looking
for your other job there's a lot that
goes into it but at the same time I mean
to get paid and to be able to make a
living playing with characters and
playing with stories and and doing
something that especially if it's
creatively fulfilling and you get paid
for it you know for people who do it
right and train themselves the right way
they literally do something that they
would do for free and they get paid and
perhaps they get paid millions of
dollars perhaps they get paid tens of
million dollars perhaps they get paid
hundreds of thousand dollars perhaps
they get paid a hundred thousand dollars
to do what you would do for free that
actually is possible and I have a
growing list of clients and students who
have that lifestyle so I think anyone
who really is drawn to this should
absolutely pursue it you know and just
pursue it in the right ways we talked
about though the beginning stages of
their career where a lot of its going to
rest on discipline and being your own
taskmaster and I think it's easy when
you think okay I have to you know get
back to this person's email on do I have
this vintage and finish well when in the
beginning is going to get a lot of time
alone right there's gonna be a lot of
time being your own task writer and how
difficult that is yeah so it is really
difficult in the beginning and a lot of
writers have this fantasy or this
illusion and I did and I was wrong is
that you know you're you're working and
you're making money and you know and
you're trying to write and you're so
busy and writing so hard and it god when
you sell something when you get hired
then you don't you can quit your day job
and you can quit this you can just write
an oh what a luxury that would be
because you're so time starved but when
you first break when I first broke in
the business you know I had two months
to write the script for metropolis but
almost every day I had meetings and I
had to go in meetings and I was talking
about other projects and pitching and I
actually was spending more time on that
than I was on my day job so I actually
had left time to write and you would
just pulled in so many directions and so
discipline really matters so one of the
things that I teach writers from the
very beginning non writers who were
starting
and then the what and a lot of them
won't do this but the ones that do not
only do they become better writers this
will save their rear ends when they have
a career is I teach them the idea of a
writer schedule so what that means is if
you have a job that pays the bills in
Thursday at 3 o'clock you have to do a
marketing proposal to your boss I know
where you're going to be Thursday at 3
o'clock you're going to be doing that
proposal if you don't feel like it and
you don't like to Fogell that good
you're still going to do the best you
can and if you feel like watching TV or
napping you're going to be there or
you're not going to have a job and you
know from 10 a.m. to 12 p.m. you are
supposed to meet with this client you're
going to do that and you schedule your
life around that so what I tell people
is no one is going to treat you like a
professional until you are a
professional no one's going to invest
money in you until you put the money
where your mouth is so you have a career
perhaps you have a family perhaps you
have all of these poles on your time I
get that every Sunday night you're going
to create a writer schedule for the next
week and maybe you can only write 45
minutes a day ideally an hour or two
hours let's say 90 minutes a day you
will block out that writing time be it
at 7:30 in the morning be it at six
o'clock whatever it is for every day for
that week now if you've blocked out
Thursday from 7:30 to 8:30 is your
writing time I know what you're going to
be at 7:30 you're going to be writing
and it's not if you feel like it because
that's like your marketing meeting with
your boss
so you schedule out your writing time
every single week and then you honor
that and if you're not willing to do
that and you're not willing to honor
that why should anyone else invest money
in you and so the writers who will
adhere to that and have that writer
schedule and stick to it before they
have a career then when they have a
career when they have that beginnings of
a career because the games are career
you have so much demands on your time
and all of these meetings that you need
to take these meetings you need to
strike while the iron is hot
you it really saves them because they'll
carve out that time and they'll put
everything around that right
time so I think a writing schedule is
really really important we talk about
managing distractions because I mean
it's one thing if someone's got a
writing schedule in 1992 but now we have
the internet we have text messages we
have even we have all right so what I
would I tell writers and what I see the
successful writers do is they live in
1992 so but they what they'll do is
often not depends let's say this person
is a morning writer so basically let's
say they get up at I don't know they get
up they do their exercise or they have
their breakfast and they have their
three hours of writing and that's going
to end at 12 o'clock from 9:00 to 12:00
so from the moment they wake up until 12
o'clock they have no internet they will
turn their router off and where you can
actually program your router to go off
or you can program it quick so they
don't check emails they don't check text
they don't check their phone they live
in a pre-internet world until 12 o'clock
and they don't their phone is turned off
now actually no one writer and I thought
this was this was brilliant they were
like just in case my wife needs to get a
hold of me they actually got a pager it
was really hard to find a pager but you
can you can actually go 1992 if you get
a pager he's got a pager and the only
person that has that number is his life
in his agent but his agent knows you
only page me if it's an emergency
and same thing with his wife and so he
has his pager there but that's all he
has no other electronics that work and
um and then at 12 o'clock he joins 2017
and he takes his meeting and or people
do that at night or the afternoon but I
would say for your writing time it party
like it's right right like it's 1992